you
we are off we're off and running here no
matter what counter pin okay I want to
keep that pin okay let's build a center
Bishop d3 92 hmm and I keep that tension
not now though I'm gonna back up my
bishop get night here mmm
I'm gonna take and try to break this
down I think this is a good idea let's
take with this really don't want to
trade bishop here if castles we still
just fish up here pawn takes Queen seems
to be short on squares here I don't know
how great that is not so great I think I
want to just vacate this square for my
Bishop Bishop there I'm going to do this
just to open up the position and open it
up some more actually it's that night up
to no good he's up to no good I'm on h6
and this pawn push of king e7 okay I
should be able to get this
let's check where are the mates they
into somewhere mate next one of these
two uni meenie miney mo on it c7 and d7
which one is it gonna be Heiser okay it
didn't happen they resigned there why am
I playing the nimzo-indian let's strike
in the center all right let's take let's
break this position open quickly
and this isn't quick enough let's do
this I'm on the bishop I'm on the pawn
take here I'm on d3 okay this is gonna
be a giant thorn it spawn right here I
want to kick that night
it's that Bishop doing bishop staring at
a pond right now Bishop on c6 and then
break at the f3 and G 2 structure
actually I like this better
everything is sealed over here after b5
if I want to go that route or Bishop c2
let's come here I need a flight square
still I have some checks I have my rook
that could play there actually I'm on
the night let's do this I should really
get a flight square in soon no not a
dark square as a flight square that was
stupid
why would I ever want to create that
kind of flight square that is ridiculous
that is so bad
h6 is much better much better okay let's
go just trade Queens
get my king up pawn push I probably
could have done it a bunch of times hang
up they don't have any time back to
Turman Wow twelve six six a bunch of
sixes alright dude dude is here Wow f5
all right give me the f5 focus on f7 wow
there's a lot of light square weaknesses
right now even over here I was ready to
move my knight he's a monster this
Knight right here pins Queen h4 looking
to take the knight and then the bishop
bishop here I could take seems to be
asking for trouble my knight needs to do
something focusing on e6 light-square
weakness now on g6 it's guard here
something here mate to me I got the
Queen actually no not so fast they
resigned back determine 1212 yeah those
light square weaknesses with that f5
move very very committal whoo long way
to go 25 minutes 32 seconds highs are
again how that happened
alright let's try this
Chazz check Benoni did this in that last
tournament stop g4 I want to trade dark
square Bishop let's go here and then
pawn push and then Knight h5 to F for a
six is also useful in fact I'm kind of
drawn to that now that there could maybe
be an open file but I'm not giving up
yet on Knight age 5 to f4 let's do this
if they give up their dark square Bishop
there's probably going to be a problem
probably going to be a problem you think
so okay now I'm on the knight pawn push
next the knight moves
or even if he doesn't come back here
pond takes I have that f4 square I'm
gonna keep that sitting just keep
advancing I thought I had that covered
enough all right now I'll take here my
dark square Bishop could spring to life
very soon okay it's gonna happen Bishop
f6
let's take here my rook belongs on b8
let's be more direct Lim just reinforce
a five okay my Knights ready to move and
then b2 is gonna be hit a lot a real lot
I don't think you could really be
defended they're down does five seconds
b2 is falling just feels like it should
be me actually they're down on time it
doesn't matter back to tournament 20s
okay
let's keep rolling can I get a quick win
in here
alright tempo on the Queen is nice build
a center I'm prepping something again
stage 7
if castles there's gonna be a problem
alright my Knights pinned let's
reinforce this build my center still
let's try to create dark square weakness
dark square weakness is what I have
right now in the night looking for a
push here pawn takes I don't recapture
I'm just gonna push if Bishop takes next
I need to take with the pawn let's do
this pawn takes I get any tempo against
the Queen I want to be timely with this
maybe even Queen III let's do this pawn
takes I get the Queen they missed that
this is check 45 seconds left
I'm gonna resign no resign okay they're
gonna try to do a counter pin let's get
castled the night is still Pandy the
knight is not hit twice the King covers
he gets checked on the rook here
probably no matter what Queen check
clean check here look check and then
look for me if King takes bishop it's me
back to tournament land 30s 3030 20s 22
minutes remaining
okay Jonathan cm oh my goodness they're
going for it fools me no it's not the
fools made anymore
it's not a fools made anymore Knight f3
I give a check I'd still give a check
here well look at that King is he wild
or what he is wild I'm crazy we're gonna
have a bunch of trades ah the game could
have ended so much sooner inside Castle
get out of there
Bishop back over here before they do
okay and I'm not even sure what that
does
oh well material back determined they
resigned forty two forty two thirty
thirty twenty twenty one minutes
remaining
the galantis this was the I played him
in the first round I pin my knight I'll
reinforce it all right whoo that was
almost a metal slick why did I take like
that do I really like my knight on this
square all right a very dull endgame but
my bishop sir
no I accept the bishop pair able to do
something with it bishop here like this
on that pawn rook here I take on f7 get
this tactic now oh now I'm just up a
rook that worked out definitely worked
out defending the bishop let's go here
trades g4 let's just take that guy
take that bishop away and then pinpoint
g7 which is close to me he's gonna March
this pawn all the way down back to turn
I was gonna push my F pawn 56:42 30s
Jonathan again
now he's doing it oh that was what you
call it on purpose
Jonathan I don't know about that
72 42 the to move kill that was what you
called the fools mate or the on purpose
mate
in that case okay
the on purpose fools me that's what you
call it the on purpose rules me all
right I'm gonna go over here before I'd
normally go to d2 but I do love dance
you got probably have to keep him out of
f4 if I could get an h4 h5 that would be
great actually I could still go here my
Queens on it so I'll take the bishop and
I'll get my Bishop on the dark diagonal
I should have played b4 so I can kick
the night and then open it up here
without allowing 95 still look for this
I'm also looking at h5 okay so I have
this in let's open up this side of the
board and even at the cost of a pond I'm
gonna do that now I have the f4 square
look at it maybe even give up the
exchange take the knight with a check
let's get Queen side developed like this
I'm not sure which way yeah take like
this I have control over this square
still with the pond we're gonna pile up
here actually let's oh my goodness do I
even see that there's some problem here
on the C file it's a matter with me okay
they missed that you can take the rook
on these past Queen here I really feel
like taking that I'm not going to though
let's come here my knight is another
check and let's go here I'm on the Queen
there's got to be some good checks Queen
c7 night here
let's take like this I guess they missed
that oh I didn't mean to do that
that's check-in here
twelve seconds okay here push
are we doing time we doing on the clock
here they resigned back to tournament
Wow they stir he really started to kick
it into a higher gear there 90 56 56 42
with less than 18 minutes remain
who a lot of big guys right there on my
heels the whole board Jerry the lover
look at this what an honor
okay let's move fast I'm okay with
giving up my bishop
that's a pawn though give him a kick
it's open this up maybe pawn push would
have been good I think yeah it would
have been good pawn push here Knight
stuff open this up pawn push there it
still have been good oh I have Queen
checks lights in a pin gonna give that
Knight up I don't want to open the
position up feel like I'm under a lot of
pressure
oh it's gonna be sac town sac Taryn
coming out I gotta do this I think there
might have been some mate well I got a
run
oh I definitely have to run the Knights
in a pin pawn push even know what that
move does Oh gives me the d4 square I
could take that night what does that
move even doing the Knights out of a pin
oh boy I can't take there oh this is
crumbling
here in a pin there down to 11 seconds
I'm gonna get maded though here where's
I'm gonna get mated or is that a save
Wow really got to do this I guess this
is leading to mate ah back to tournament
oh I had a time lead oh man that was
brutal I think there was even some mate
I think there was a sacrifice you have
to look back on that I think there was a
Brooke aged eight mate and then the
Queen coming over to the h-file
attacking my h2 square I didn't have F
to defend it either ah surprisingly
still believe in this tournament I
should I had that game maybe maybe I'm a
fan of that maybe word you didn't
realize okay push and then break this
pin hmm I think Bishop takes and then
maybe grab here would have been
something let's get on this main
diagonal and then I guess just double up
on the e-file hang on um I guess I get
the d5 square of kicked take the knight
oh oh
let's take here on the bishop there's
back rank stuff take like this I need a
flight square this isn't the greatest
flight square could I've just taken the
Queen did they just give like check and
I could have taken stuff my knight back
here queen g4 tricky stuff on f7 maybe
get back here back here I wanna function
on these light squares I should offer to
Queen trade
get her get rid of this rook here no
matter what I'm on the bishop I take
that pond everything under control I
just want to keep pushing that pond on
the bishop maybe still just push the
pond and push it one more
the knight is there to defend well
centralized I take the knight soon
though me now and keep going one more
I'm ready to give a check and then
promote check on f4 and then promote the
King probably has to go to g7 here and
then I promote take here anything
where's the mate it's not it there's the
mate
their down time they're down on time
back to tournament 108 90 oh man 108 90
82 beyond the halfway point
13 13 minutes remain
I could really go for a granola bar and
the h2 square okay I'd have six Oh No
let's do this I still like this idea to
induce some weakness against the Kings
side try to make one of these two pawns
flinch and weaken the dark squares like
right now pawn push I have g3 since
sensitive it's definitely sensitive
Queen takes is maybe best I'm gonna do
this though are they gonna give up their
dark square Bishop I was thinking about
this but the bishop is on the night if
they do that Bishop here could be
annoying if the knight moves I could
maybe get the bishop with check-in some
lines open up the file I have bishop
here next very strong diagonal now I
want to just smash through on this point
my queen on e7 I never try to be sneaky
about this the Knights in a pin I'll
take that
I'm still making two or three two or
three here we go made on f2 the scholars
made square the scholars made square
back determined once 28 122 90 less than
12 minutes remaining deep breaths
128 120 290 88 88 all right I need a
quick strike English probably not gonna
happen let me build a center mm-hmm I
need more support for still gonna get
this in that's very weakening very
weakening light square weaknesses I
could I could counter I can counter it
like this if Queen to e7 okay castle
rook e1 very quick I have the bishop
pair now and my bishop is really strong
here hang on let's check my bishop
certainly belongs here Knight g5 Queen
on h4 Queen f3 h3 Knight to e6 if kicked
let's kick the Queen my bishop might be
attacked actually I could take this pawn
I can move the pawn as well and hit the
Queen that's easily overlooked there's
also a fork not anymore
let's kick the Queen I'm dropping this
pawn but there probably should be some
me Oh
let's kick here this should be blasted
right up and I actually could have taken
this Knight a bunch on the rook
when this rook here just throw my knight
in here pawn push as well Knight here
hit the Queen and then come here with
Czech pawn push next on b7 26 seconds
anything anything anything oh I had a
fork
here no matter what
where's the time had that fork where the
forks where are those forks here we go
discoveries oh that's me
Queen Esther block there down on time
though back to tournament 148 142 128
110 okay
c5 all right I gotta go for this
positional line I guess that's gonna
kill me it's gonna kill me
the adobe flash gambit happening
sometime soon to give him a kick
maybe I should taken with the knight and
welcome a dark square bishop exchanged
all right
takes here I could take and defend my
knight all right my knight on F floor is
going to be a monster I don't want that
trade no no no no no no I like my knight
too much
I want my knight on f4 gave up the
bishop but I have a lot of play right
here actually probably taking the knight
is really good but they take here next
so let me do not enough I want to do
this maybe I don't even know what that
does it's like a passing move okay so
much for this Knight stuff he defended
it what about b5 now I guess we'll try
this take the pawn with check I want to
keep my structure a time edge now I'm
gonna be up upon they can't even take
back am I not moving
what does that do I want to keep the
Queen there the rooks on the board
otherwise it's too much with just the
Queen's for perpetual x' and stuff go
check here I guess go here some more
checks happening
I don't even know what that move does on
defense stuff my Queens here how much
time I go quick be five already sneak
attack they're down on time back to
chairman hmm man 168 148 140 802 too
close too close to call too tight a pack
up there oh man
d5 I'm gonna take with my pawn no matter
what no not necessarily no matter what
this seems really appealing and take
like that so their king is on castled
how can I open the position up I'm gonna
keep Queens on the board this move King
is running for his life even know that's
such a half developing move can't stand
it I can't stand how half developing
what what a half developing move that is
pawn push and then Bishop g5 get a
better Queen position first she's there
to watch over this pawn I'd really like
their knight to move is this too crazy
to do g4g 5 and then 95 with tempo I'm
gonna give it a shot Bishop takes I take
here g5 Knight d5 with tempo I still
have him defended ok now I get this on
the Queen and now Bishop to hang on
right here with check and now I have the
Queen ok next phase is just move fast
and look for pieces to kill 188 168 168
160
oh did I must look no I didn't know slip
anything I got the c5 move in
successfully ok did I ever play this guy
before
no this always ends up defending against
my tricks but I can open up the H file
and that could still be scary all right
actually I'm winning material something
I don't want because I need more
development in maybe a little bit later
though all right let's do this
take care my queen could be quite good
on this square but should be seven she's
very very strong right here in the
center cannot be kicked so easily no
dark square Bishop Brown no pawn to hit
the Queen and they're lining things up
but I have this check over here on c5
now that the knight isn't on b3 clean
trade maybe is happening soon with Queen
f2 I guess I'm okay with that actually I
like this much better I'm on g3 I'd like
to pinpoint that again here seems very
appealing actually here on threatening
Knight takes pawn 26 seconds I'll do
this because now I get a four take the
pawn the rook back in night III or just
that King position don't need to castle
at this point my rook is doing a good
job I'm dropping my bishop or am i okay
i get this pawn at the end unless Bishop
b4 nope they're going for this I just
want to get rid of their knight rid of
that Knight
and things should be okay I'm getting
rid of that night he cannot be tolerated
nope
cannot deal with that Knight I mean I
could but I just don't want to push take
here and get these guys over here and
then push here no matter what here
nearly no matter what you're doing
timewise pushing inch by inch it comes
at a snail's pace but it's making good
progress here get a queen here they're
actually made it
okay 208 188 188 okay don't agree with
this guy's name otherwise I would not be
playing
Chaz is amazing that's that's the first
username he tried to track down there
all right queen g4 now that the knight
isn't around pawn push my dark squared
Bishop is happy let's make sure c5 isn't
even gonna happen the night's gone
they might resign this could be a quick
win or can it they still can't castle
pawn push I take this pawn let's come
back here get the Queen they're trying
to go in the other direction let's do
this
now we're gonna end up trading I want to
throw my knight right here they're gonna
do d5 nope now their bishops dead
they're looking to go after my king
maybe but I have everything secure
everything is secure here except for my
second rank that's secure now alright
King here guard this move my bishop
Knight e4 Knight e4 let's take this pawn
move my knight back actually bishop here
is a good spot
push he's a passed pawn and he needs to
be pushed my Knights gonna get right
back into action come on here here oh my
goodness I thought for a second there
might have been an accident over here on
D 3 d3 they're gonna they're gonna pre
move that okay I can still do this down
to less than 10 take here bishop return
to d5 and then promote matin to maybe
down on time they resigned back
determined to forty eight to forty eight
to twenty eight to twenty one forty five
I got thrown a sneaky tactic or
something one forty again he's never
gonna fall for his scholars it's just
not happening okay yeah it's not
happening but can I do something like
this
not really yeah this is turned very
positional very positional why am i
cancelling over here
Queen check I'm okay with this ending I
have the better Bishop I push here my
king wants to be on e7 the case this
pawn is exposed pawn push might be good
let's take and do this he's gonna be
weak he's gonna be weak and he's gone
he's gone he's down on the rook I get
control of this I don't want to take and
change the structure they're gonna come
over here nope okay I want to get back
over on f4 with this check probably no
matter what now I should have really
done that that's okay hon push no no no
no no no g5 they might clamp down ah
they blew the whistle on this one
it's already over second place confetti
what tournament brutal 268 228 220 220
188 Wow
I didn't say good games last time good
games all tough tough tournament 72
players were in that one or at least at
the end right here very very tense 19
games in 1717 so it's a legit tournament
there sometimes he could get out of
control
if there's a sneakiness going on but uh
that was I was a clean good tournament
nice
you